[Music]
it was a great day to be a dad on Sunday
Kevin Hart brought his nine-year-old son
Hendrix for premiere of his new movie
Captain Underpants and you know what
Nancy
I couldn't let Kevin know the fun I
decided to bring with me
Shane Frazier you focused you ready Wow
Wow what the coolest part of your dad
playing and captured under bit when he
pranks people best prank ever
good answer son yeah Kevin pranks a lot
of people in the movie especially the
school principal Captain Underpants what
do you think stuff for you or catalyst
for Dad there you go good job dude
you're fired a hey Kevin is quite the
supportive dad especially in sports down
when he comes to your games how crazy
does he get more think we why do I get
crazy cuz you want us to score that's
right we go out you see there you go
it's all coming from a place of love
I'm surprised you not out here cheering
feed somebody was Mitt answer to my
coaches team I coach the team
oh you coaching team are you crazy dad
great okay all right good like mad you
know like he is mad he doesn't like
cheers yeah you're on TV right now you
don't tell secrets were on team we got
personal TV we're on TV okay okay i Shan
is adorable and I'm mad at you now I
clearly have to train him on what not to
say on television no he's honest and you
need to be hated me Shane
[Music]
you